privacy is the cost of Fame and for some
people that cost is always too much for
me I'm not really that different in
private than I am publicly so it it
didn't seem like too big of a deal
second is it's irreversible once
everyone knows who you look like that's
it you can't stop and uh there's like
small social costs like you know if I
walk outside of the house I'll get
recognized four or five times and that's
fine or if I go to dinner with Lila I'll
probably have to stop three or four
times during the dinner to take pictures
and that can be disrupting and the hard
part is you always have to be in the
best mood ever because this is the one
time that this person will ever see you
and they will make 100% of their
lifelong judgment and tell every person
they ever meet how you are based on the
30 seconds of how you interact with them
and then 10 minutes later you do it
again